my name is Rachel Justine and I'm 27 I'm
based out of Austin Texas and this is
financial audit what do you do for a
living in Austin Texas uh my main thing
is I am a spiritual coach okay
interesting no yeah yeah yes it's you're
fine what happened nothing H how does
that go how does that go um it's like
therapy or it's not therapy it's it's a
hybrid between
um online coaching uh online courses and
yeah and also now that you know things
are opened back up I'm doing inperson
things and it's a hybrid of like yoga
meditation uh life coaching upliftment
and all the things that I'm not an
expert at but I can actually put
together any go ahead essentially
guiding people into feeling good and
fulfillment in their life okay and how
successful are you in this um not it's a
work in progress yeah it's a work in
progress okay yeah uh well so do you
feel good in life and all that stuff I I
do I've had um well I've had a lot of uh
shifts in the last few years that really
changed my life and made going for this
my dream and my passion and um so yeah
it's it's a continual journey and of
course there's ups and downs ups and
downs I'm curious about uh a down right
now talk about passions do you have a
passion for credit card debt um this is
kind of crazy I I don't think I got my
first credit card until like two years
ago this was all within the last two
years this wasn't even built up go
on this [__] this okay hm yeah
you see the Fai that I said when she did
spiritual cult is the same face he did
when like
this
shat all
right yeah so I hadn't um I hadn't had
the experience with credit cards and at
all and didn't
understand okay I didn't understand
there was like different seasons of the
work and there were times of making more
and then making less so it became this
you to do like Market Research into this
industry before you decided this is what
we're doing fulltime
um not in the sense of like I just saw
coaches who were just constantly making
you know 40K months and ,000 a month
uhhuh that'd be nice I know right that's
what I'm saying yeah so that was like
that's where the head was at my head was
at so you you were more into the money
than helping people you saw people that
were coaches other coaches that were
making that kind of money and you're
like I want to make that kind of money
so that's the reason why it's a hybrid
and not something that you really it's
all the things that you think you
believe in but you're not really an
expert at you masch it together and you
make you're a charlatan and also most of
those coaches not make it 40K no it's
Instagram they're just faking lifestyle
but they'll sell you on it but you're
the person who gets dm' by some random
person hay you want to make 10K a day
and you believe that [__] it's stupid
they don't make 40K a month they don't
make 40K a month if you 95% of people on
Instagram are lying or scamming or lying
about their follower account they lying
about how much money they make they
lying about how many women they get what
Lambos they drive all this [__] yo the
amount of people I know who buy fake
followers is insane on social media they
they they they either get it through
their production companies their
agencies they all got fake followers you
can normally tell just by the [__]
interactions with their content like
they'll have like 40,000 likes and like
50 comments or they'll have 300 comments
but for some reason they're all from
India not Bollywood actresses it's crazy
so it's all fake and her saying she
bought into that then you shouldn't be a
coach of anything yep it's spiritual to
want for K mon yeah super spiritual oh
yeah super spiritual all these [__]
expensive jewelries nice hats hats all
that stuff all you coaches that's cuz
Buddha wanted it all you coaches out
there all you you you life coaches and
[__] like that when you come up to me
like I'm a l life coach I'm going to be
like mm bro charlatan spiritual people
who are obsessed with material
possessions always make me laugh I'm
going tell you that much most people
that I've seen being life coaches most
people that I've seen being life coaches
they like life is in chambles and it's
okay that's most of us but I'm not going
about there teaching to other people
teaching to people and when my [__] is
my my [__] is [__] up I don't go I
don't I don't I I don't go yeah charging
people it's it's even worse I don't go
out there throwing rock some people's
lives saying you should do this should
do that well my life is not together so
let's let's listen and how much you
bringing in a month it varies average
give me an average let's work with an
average here break it down between the
low months High months what's the
average cross just a brief pause to ask
you to please consider subscribing look
how close we are to 100,000 subscribers
thank you to everyone who has subscribed
so far and back to the video uh I would
say a low month could be anywhere from 2
3,000 okay to um an average is I would
say 6500 okay that's not that at all
that's your average that's not your high
that's your average that's an average
okay 6,500 fantastic what's the complain
about that um she says her average per
month is 6,500 yeah if she's there
because there's a prom we'll find
up for how long have you been doing this
full time uh I mean in the last few
years okay so a couple years bring in
personal business to pretty much $8,000
a year people would love that I mean
you're $5,000 over the median household
income in Austin and well above the
median in the United States and it's
just you yeah why are we in this debt in
the first place we haven't even talked
about it we'll go into it but why
$80,000 a year why yeah why are you in
this debt why you get into it why are
you not out of it what is happening
that's a question I mean it's on my
vision board to have all my debts be
cleared so okay um I think it that's
where yeah I didn't really understand
the nature of having a credit card so I
started making more money than I ever
had in the last two years from this from
this when you start making more money
than you than I ever have made it
started like TW uh 2020 like okay spring
2020 yeah and credit card debt started
19 18 2020 same yeah like I didn't get
my credit card until after I started
making this yeah mhm
okay how much is in your teing account
right now I cannot see that on here
what's in your te account uh over 4,000
4,000 okay I am happy with that that's
awesome $4,000 in the check game mhm
everything in here is just mostly paying
off well not paying off cards but paying
towards cards and you do it in a very
interesting way we have like a mobile
payment here is $60 and a Spotify
subscription and a mobile payment of $60
then we have we're ven out $2,100 like
is that what are we doing that's my rent
your portion yes I live alone oh so
that's your landlord you your landlord
okay yeah cuz that 6500 is Prett tax
which talk about that in a second and
then corporate fining LLC I I think I
understand that now with the business
and stuff so okay and then we're
spending money at Starbucks and we're
vening out the dollar and then again
here come the moment payments again we
have $100 we have $60 we have $60 we
have $50 we have check card Arc my chart
$100 okay I only like that $100
something that you can't think of but
gate will continue with a mobile payment
of $50 Mobile payment of
$50 and Go Daddy payment website that's
starting to make more sense and same
with the square spacing then we have
Mobile payment $120 again we're just
getting all this in a class pass for $69
class pass yeah that's a workout class
oh okay and there's your Squarespace and
the Capital One mobile payment of
$165 and Mobile payment of $100 and then
it looks like with this there's another
one $60 but it looks like your T-Mobile
bill I have the top plan of T-Mobile 70
bucks uh I think that's the top plan but
yours is 9949 that's making me think
that phone right there is not owned that
is financed it is owned now it's owned
now like you just paid it off officially
cuz this is 99 bucks yeah it's been but
that's just the rate it used to be like
120 a month what plan are you on are you
not on the automatic payment cuz that
also brings it down by like five bucks
i' look at that cuz you do not need to
be on that plan I promise you I get
coverage everywhere here for 70 bucks a
month unlimited okay not plug for them
but you're spending $30 more there when
you have a lot of bad debt and again we
just have mobile payments and mobile
payments Apple subscriptions mobile
payments mobile payments mobile payments
for years and years is pages of mobile
payments it's just brutal how often this
going on now one thing I do not like
what we have here if we have money going
into acorns right now and subscriptions
for acorns and acorns is great if you
don't have really bad debt you can sign
up for acorns in the description below
and get a free five bucks and you put
five bucks in which is great but it
doesn't make any sense for you to do
this right now because you have so much
debt thoughts comments investing in
acorns when you have all this crap debt
so actually that so that one I still
have that account open um but it was
like that was one of the accounts that I
had is like the reserve you know like so
I I hit a rough month or something I
need money like I had that because ACN
you have savings account option no I
just was using it as like an investment
save saving while speaking of that you
took $800 out of it then you took
another $300 out yeah I needed all of
that to come out why I had why $6,500 a
month do you need that I hit one of the
slow down periods um so you're not good
at saving money then if because if we're
looking at the average that's great but
the high months you need to have that
money set aside okay yeah you're in tax
Taxas so no income tax here it'll
probably be closer to 25 but you need to
set money aside you're going to get into
a bad situation where the IRS come to
knock on your door huh I I don't know
how not to touch the sa you know like I
thought about getting a safety deposit
box so that way it's like away from me
you can have a couple different kind of
savings cuz yes now okay so why why why
can't you why why do you always touch
the money I feel like like something
always happens well well that's why we
have an emergency fund if there's an
emergency and you don't have the money
to pay for it you take it from there you
don't want to take tax money this is why
we haven't even talked about an
emergency fund but that would be the
extra $20,000 but you never touch it
unless you have to but what always
happens what are you doing in your life
that you're always getting into some
kind of pickle cuz usually recognizing
that you're able to then counteract that
in life you know but if you're just
always getting into it then clearly
something's wrong can you give us any
examples what what's
happening um well I think I when I
started making more money I wasn't used
to making that much money and um so like
I went from before like always you know
just barely getting by and then when I
had money start coming in you buy stupid
[__] yes you you buy stupid [__] and and
on top of that when I got my first
credit card it was like oh now I have
this money and now I don't even need to
spend this money I can spend this credit
card money and then it was like it just
felt really good and so it was you know
and then wanting to live in a mindset of
abundance so it's like I want to buy why
why live in a mindset of abundance what
that oh cuz it feels good I'm glad we
doing things that feel
good a mindset of abundance I don't even
know what the [__] that is it's just a
way of saying that you're
materialistic a mindset of abundance
it's my mind it's not your mindset that
is abundant you have a lot of [__] and
it makes you feel good you are a
Shopaholic okay that's just a [__]
spirituality term to say that you you no
[__] that [__] and that's what all
that's what all you [__] coaches do
reupholster some to make it look good
that's what you do oh no you're not a
bad person you're just such and such and
such so much that being materialistic
being a [__] shopaholic someone that
cannot control yourself and you having
no discipline you reupholster that into
a mindset of abundance and that's you
charlatan do that's what you guys do
that's what the you guys do and then you
go out there and you make other people
feel good you have no expert in what the
you're doing but you're good at making
other people feel good about what do
they make them feel good about
themselves about about their shopaholic
beh what no no but you see what say may
be enabling some of the bad [__] too no
you exactly you're a bunch of enablers
and that's what you do it's not so much
making you feel good about the shaa
thing it's making you feel good about
all the thought if you feel good you're
going to spend more this is a this is a
marketing thing if you feel good you is
good no it's not even that if you feel
good you're going to spend more that's a
marketing thing that's why some some
casinos they pump oxygen there's bright
colors you don't pay for the alcohol if
you feel good you're spending good and
if I'm the one that's making you feel
good you're going to be more willing to
give me your money that's what you are
doing whoa whoa can you chill out I said
what I said I didn't stutter that's what
you are doing you
charlot charlatans out there that's what
you're doing and some of you don't even
realize that you're doing that but
you're doing that okay okay of just
smart okay that makes sense um so as a
spiritual coach uh and like helping
people do things do you know that that
mindset is complet and has put you in a
bad position um the mindset that you
just explained not your whole spiritual
thing but the mindset of abundance and
it feels good to spend money bull it's
hurting you mhm do you
agree well I think now like in
retrospect I can see where
there were things you know now after
being in this more financial tight spot
which I haven't experienced in the last
two and a half years um because of the
increasing debt and because of um having
a slow down month whereas usually I had
more money because I had less was paying
less on my credit cards I had more money
and then I you know was running out and
the um and then I started to like I went
through everything and I actually
canceled so much stuff like
subscriptions and I was just realizing
like I didn't think I could do that you
know like I thought after it was so it
was like ego deflating to be like I
guess I don't need to go to see like the
most expensive hair stylist or I don't
need to go get a blowout or you know
like all these things that felt really
good um your lifestyle just inflated
with that money but it over inflated and
now you're position financially to be
very clear but we're going to Hope find
ways out of it uh but the taxes that's
all we talked about so far we haven't
even got into the credit card de we
haven't even gotten into the carard de
we haven't got into you not having an
emergency fund being able to survive so
so far not so good credit card
Deb yeah so it's just it's always hard
to just get into because this is this
this is so bad and I don't want to hurt
you but this is so I'm here I this is
this is something this is something that
pisses me off more than almost anything
in the world we have a previous balance
of
$1,846 $299 payments cool we are making
progress yay progress is happening
fantastic we about to buy a bunch of
dumb [__] cuz we got a mindset of
abundance so yay but guess what we're
doing
$343 67 of purchases we're purchasing
more than was even paid on when we're
already basically at the credit limit of
$2,000 and while that's all happening
$41.59 of interest is being charged why
are you purchasing $44,000 in your
checking C bring what $6,500 a month why
you purchasing on a card that is already
almost maxed
out um I kind of do this been doing this
dance uh with like credit cards where um
I don't want to spend the money that I
have like I feel like it makes more
sense to like if I'm going out to eat or
whatever you know buying something from
Amazon if I need you know like a
household need um then I would rather do
it from the credit card pay off the
credit card so I have more money pay off
the credit card you're not paying off
the credit card you spent more than you
paid off and you're losing an additional
$41.59 in interest you're losing that
because you're doing that you know that
does that make sense yeah the interest
sucks the interest sucks it absolutely
does it is time to find a new dance
partner instead of these credit cards
that is just that's terrible you spend
the money when you have the money if you
don't have the money you don't spend the
money it's okay don't make don't make
fun of the laugh people have made fun of
the laugh it's the normal coping
mechanism when someone is confronting
you so is okay this guy's good he's good
whoa he's really who's who's this guy uh
Financial audit what's his name I don't
know I just call him Financial that's
his channel this guy is good don't make
fun of the laugh that's what
that's a good call out by the
way that's good Jesus Christ and I don't
want you to be sitting here thinking
that I'm here making the
Good Financial choices all the time okay
what pisses me off is not that she's
making the Good Financial choices or the
bad financial choices that I don't care
about that it's okay we we all have our
flaws and stuff like that I wouldn't
care about the fact that she's I don't
care that she's materialistic I don't
care that she likes nice things I don't
care that she wants to pamper herself I
don't care about none of that and I'm
not even sitting here saying I B better
CH choices than her the difference is
and what pisses me off uhuh what' you
say I didn't say nothing what the [__]
did you say whoa can you not be so
aggressive what the [__] did you say I
didn't say nothing yes you
did so now you're calling me stupid in
my face is that what you're doing is
that what we're doing no no I'm just
replicating Behavior I've seen you do is
you recognize what I just
did yeah but I say it in your face and
you know damn well as no you don't damn
well you s right into the camera
go that's want to try ones I never tried
it thanks how does it feel
snaky a
lot but anyways all have to say uh yeah
they're judging her basically because
she's giving advice to people I don't no
she's charging yeah yeah exactly exactly
um it's like it feels like I mean it's
hard not to spend this is going to be
offensive I have to be offensive I the
spiritual advice and all that stuff on
the other side I don't understand
exactly what you're saying we can talk
about that uh but I don't know what's
said in there are you in a place or you
should be giving that kind of advice to
people if you can't even stop yourself
from something that's basic as spending
uh touchdown not going to play we're
going to do a redo but we're going to
have to do a conversion punt uh yeah you
just made up a bunch of [__] but yes
touchdown two point conversion made all
the points yes absolutely I got you yeah
I made sport not your Forte it's okay
yes I made a whole you said you went
touchdown flag on the play uh and we G
do conversion uh kick punt yes okay home
run it's okay it's all good I at you bro
go touchdown seven points yeah of course
I put everything in there okay well I
don't get people Financial advice I know
not Financial advice but life advice if
you can't even take control of your own
misbehavior should you be giving advice
to other
people well I think maybe not Financial
but life advice you're not taking
control of your life
and finances whether we like it or not
is a huge part of our life but this is a
part of your life and you cannot control
your spending you just admitted so so
should you in fact be giving advice to
other people if you cannot control an
aspect of your life that is clearly
wrong I'm definitely willing to shift it
you're spending mhm good why haven't you
though well I have in since the last
month in December uh I had to like I had
to cut back on things you didn't cut
back on anything we just went through
all this it's a 50 honest Maries what
are you cutting back there's no cut back
you I cut back on things that you're not
seeing now oh dude no this has to stop
and that's why these are all maxed out
let's c one what did we do
here this guy I like this guy because
he's he's backing up everything that he
says he's backing up everything that he
says and it's like when even when he's
like dude no stop he's calling the
[__] right away so what does real
cutting back look like no honest marries
you know you can't afford to go out
right you know you can't afford to buy
any designer clothes you know you cannot
afford to go to anything but great clubs
you know you cannot afford to go out to
eat at all right to be very clear not a
single
time I'm
speechless do you know you cannot afford
that though I get my lot I feel like it
saves me so much time though so I can
work on my business work on your how
many hours a day are you working it
depends and now I'm doing more things
now average an average how many days or
hours a day are you working
five then you don't have time that's
stupid that's the stupidest thing I've
ever heard I want to watch that [__]
again you need to bring that [__] back
sir I want to watch that [__] back again
sir bring it back how many days hours a
day are you working five then you don't
have time that's stupid that's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard I'm
sorry I'm digging into you but that's
dumb that's dumb and you need to know
that's dumb that's why I'm being
rough put that guy up for presidency God
D for 5 hours a day oh poor me I'm
working 5 hours a day and I can't cook
what do you mean it saves you time are
you taking out from Hest Mar's every day
or you go and eat there I take it out
okay yeah well at least that's a thing
but 5 hours a day working you can
congratulations
cook you
can there are 19 more
hours oh no there's 18 more hours take
away eight of them to sleep 10 more
hours
uhhuh we can't make a bowl of mac and
cheese in 10 hours put chicken in the
oven for in 10 hours I'm confused I'm
very confused can you do are you
understanding this are you going to try
to justify you got to give me something
here I'm just talking to a wall well cuz
I like to eat very that's part of my
spiritual life is eating that's part of
my spiritual life is eating whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoaaa let me make sure I hear
that part D are you understanding this
are you going to try to justify you got
to give me something here I'm just
talking to a wall well cuz I like to eat
very that's part of my spiritual life is
eating get the [__] out of here a [__]
get the [__] out of here you know what
this is like there's nothing spiritual
about what you do bro you know what this
is like this is like when religious
people just justify everything with God
yeah it's God that let God handle it
it's God that make me want to sing on
the plane it's God that made me want
[__] God didn't acrew all that interest
rate that's you [__] that's you being
irresponsible that's you wanted to buy
fancy cars and do all this other dumb
[__] you wanted to go to the store bro
you wanted to buy designer
Gucci whatever it is that's you don't
put that on God to find the solution to
a problem that a
manmade and then you want to use
spirituality to eat healthy lady do you
know what's really eating healthy taking
care of your own food watching the salt
intake watching the quantities of oil
involved making sure you get the right
vegetables it's not true that part of
your spiritual life is to eat healthy
cuz if it was you would be taking care
of make sure you get the best but you
eat out not because of spiritual life
cuz you're lazy and guess what you can
go eat out if you can afford to but you
in this much that you can don't if you
can afford I got nothing to say but
you're maxing out credit cards talking
about spiritual life this is what
happens people will use their ideology
to Shield them from any
accountability and it's disgusting
because it really reflects poorly on the
ideology I think that's a shame I've
known many spiritual people in my life
they don't talk like this and they're
not this irresponsible this is just a
grift in my opinion the real life life
coach in all this is him that dude yeah
that's the real life coach in all this
true calling your [__] out real life
Co is going to be a financial
advisor telling you you spend too much
on this and that and if you want your
life to be better you need to do this a
life coach is going to be your doctor
telling you you need to do this and do
that and you know that all those smokes
and all those cigarettes that you're
taking you shouldn't do that that's a
life coach you know very healthy buy
some R lce H be I don't care sorry
continue I interrupted it's
and it just it costs more to eat healthy
yes even if at like the grocery store
like it really does as much as you are
spending you don't have to get the top
of the line organic crap to be healthy
just don't eat Pand Express every day
like I do it would I think it would take
just some open-mindedness or seeing what
else is possible for shopping I how to
save in shopping we need to go on a
shopping trip we might need to go on a
shopping trip let me know if you guys
need a bonus episode of us going on a
shopping trip all right I'm gonna stop
it there you guys can go watch the rest
of the episode because it's good there's
a lot it's over an hour long but I want
to take a second to watch this because
Financial stress is a real thing there
are certain things in the economy and
you know in terms of job availability
that made things a lot more difficult
for people but a lot of it is also a lot
of personal choice I know too many poor
people who are eating out on a regular
basis maxing out credit cards all this
other stuff playing bball out behind the
school um
and when you engage in that behavior it
[__] you up and that's self-destructive
and then you're going to blame it on
everything around you in circumstances
but no that's really you doing that to
yourself so I don't know I I just hear
this like her maxing out credit cards
and just doing the minimum payment that
gives me super anxiety I just could
never I have two credit cards one for my
business and one for my personal life my
personal life I never touch it unless
I'm running through expensive through my
business and when I used to touch my
personal thing I only spent as much as I
knew I could pay if I didn't know I
could pay it easily at the end of the
month I didn't touch it I was not buying
stuff for a long time they would hit me
up you want a credit limit increase no
you want a credit limit increase no why
cuz my income I I knew I don't even want
to increase that ceiling I was never
someone who spent like that but let's
say I wanted to I wanted to make sure
that I would just pay it off you know
what sometimes I would do if I knew I
had to make an expense that was beyond
my credit limit you know what I used to
do I used to make a payment on my credit
card before so went it's the negative it
that's a smart that's a smart [__]
[__] to do if you don't got the
discipline to do certain things create
an environment where you're less likely
to break do you understand if you're not
good with sugar create an environment
where you won't easily get access to
sugar
don't keep it in the house tell your
family like please can y'all help me on
this whatever you got to do you know the
thing is go ahead I used to be I used to
do both be bad with my money and do
better with my money okay the difference
between being bad with my with my money
and making the bad decisions okay is
that the gra gratification you get right
now but the stress you get later yeah
with discipline is the opposite you're
kind of H it's not fun yeah but the
gratification you get later because
you're able to do much more things yeah
and that's the thing it's like a bit how
your body works in the intake of oxygen
and intake of uh carbon monoxide your
body can take easier carbon monoxide and
process it but in the end you end up
dying sure where oxygen is harder to
process but you get to live it's the
same thing the discipline gets boring at
first it really just like uh I got to do
this and that and I got to be an adult
but at the end you could sleep at
night yeah someone someone someone said
that too they said discipline is
freedom Y and it sounds counterintuitive
but discipline is giving you the tools
to have a free life free from a lot of
the negative consequences that no
discipline offers you cuz when your life
is in chaos you're just behold to
circumstance yeah interest taxes debt
whatever the [__] it is you know when
your life is chaos it's random people
coming in causing problems but when
you're disciplined you're much more
centered you're much more controlled and
as a result of that you're you're able
to have some freedom and take control of
things that are immediate so yeah it was
one of those interesting quotes like
discipline affords you Freedom yeah but
when I save my money I can spend it
later but you don't get that freedom
right away no whereas spending your
money not being discipline you get the
sense of Freedom right away but it's
really just a sense it's just really
hidden can you say you're free you say
you're free a year from now when you got
all this debt they've canceled all your
credit card and you can't go anywhere
and you're in debt and you can't buy
nothing so is that freedom you don't
feel it right away YOLO right you only
live
once but you pay taxes a lot YOLO you
only live once and you're about to live
a lot lot shorter if you keep yelling
YOLO your one life that you only live is
going to be a substantially
shorter anyways I'm just saying so
I interesting video we want to hear your
takes in the below what are some
Financial tips that you guys had to
avoid debt or get out of debt that you
guys may have accumulated hopefully for
all people stressing and dealing with it
now I hope you guys take it seriously
your credit score it matters your stress
levels they matter and until you take
that seriously above taking random trips
and all that stuff you will never be
able to feel free you have shackles you
might not be able to see them but they
there and they get in Tighter and
Tighter and don't let them get to the
point where they start cutting off your
circulation cuz then [__] is too late
and then we got to have cut off
flims so I don't want that for you guys
I don't want that for you guys all right
so that's all for today